everybody
foreign
interesting
questions
yes good morning everybody
um welcome to Timber's District
council's planning committee on the 25th
of October it's just about 10 o'clock
so we're going to make a start can I
welcome all members and we have um
speakers and guests with us as well can
I introduce you to the officers I have
with me at the top table at the moment
um
Rosen Eastman business manager Tris
Combs Democratic Services officer
Suzanne Warford legal department
Jennifer Jewell our officer and Chris
Morgan and Sarah Selway Democratic
Services I'm councilor lingelman
Bradbury I'm going to be chairing the
meeting today so you're very welcome
here
um can I just remind you obviously we're
in a public building we're not expecting
a fire alarm I do have to take you
through that kind of convention if you
do hear the fire alarm please make your
way to the car park
foreign
can I ask if you have a mobile phone
with you if you could turn it to silent
and if you're to all members and members
of the committee if you're not here for
the whole debate on the application that
we're looking at today you cannot you're
not able to vote on the application
please raise your hand when you wish to
speak and when the gentleman will come
to you with a microphone please speak
clearly into that
um
okay
forward to the
sorry lots of paper on my desk here this
morning
so forward to the agenda
apologies for absence
I have a counselor Nuttall Hayes
Peart
Haynes and Hugh Cooks
um councilor Russell if she turns up in
the next few minutes we'll be
substituting for cancer appeared
thank you our members content to accept
the list of apologies as
declared please can I see a show of
hands please
thank you
um we'll then move on to
um
sorry I've got too much on my desk
minutes apologies minutes of the last
meeting
our members
see councilor Dewhurst he's already had
his hand raised maybe with a question
but our members have content for me to
sign this is a true record of the last
meeting on the 27th of September
counselor
love it thank you chair
um under item sorry under item 10 uh
Declarations of Interest it states that
I declared an interest in application 20
stroke uh 00961 stroke m a j I didn't I
declared an uh an interest in I've got
the first two numbers
00572 the the field
and
um I'm the owner of a caravan Park so
thank you we will have that corrected
for you thank you Jeff um could I have a
proposer with um the minutes with that
Amendment and the secondary please
Council yeah Council Dewhurst is happy
to propose I can see councilor Nutley
indicating he's happy to second
so can we go to the voter for accepting
the uh the minutes with that Amendment
please
foreign
against
any abstentions
I can see four
thank you
that's carried chair thank you that's
carried we're going to move on to
Declarations of Interest any members
have a declaration of interest for any
items before us
uh thank you uh as I said last time as a
boat owner who in the past has laid up a
boat in this yard for the winter I'm
declaring an interest in this
application and withdrawing from taking
part in the determination of this
application coupled with the fact that I
know the after going quite well and I
feel it only right and proper that
others should determine this application
and that's 20 stroke the application
number is 20 stroke zero zero nine six
one major Riverside boat yard thank you
councilor Clarence any other
Declarations of interest on this item
cancer Nutley
future
um yeah I think as before uh declare an
interest obviously in receiving
documents but also this comes under part
of my pH
thank you so are you intending to to not
vote on the item or just your job
to seem any reason to not to vote that's
fine thank you
okay we'll move on to the next item then
thank you
um
so public participation please
foreign
we have
um three speakers one objector and two
supporters for this application
okay thank you
um can I um also point out to members
that we are going to have a roll call
vote just to make sure we've got Clarity
on the numbers
um for this item
members of the public when it is your
turn to speak I'll call you to the front
of the meeting to address the committee
you will have
um
10 minutes to speak
um however we have two members of the
public who wish to to come along as
supporters so you will have five minutes
each
I believe that's the case yeah so I just
clarify yeah we have one objector so as
it's a major application uh they have 10
minutes and supporters we have two
people speaking so they have five
minutes each thank you
okay thank you for that clarification so
um if I could and
um first of all obviously uh refer to
the planning Officer Jennifer Joel to
set this in for the item
sorry
okay hello
um so I'm going to be explaining the
scheme today so no this application is
for a mixed use development and it is
for a mix of industrial employment well
employment comprising industrial and
office nine dwellings and 16 units of
holiday accommodation
so site location I'm sure you will be
familiar it is on the edge of Tim Murph
it is within the Estuary environment
within the riveting environment
and it is just to the immediate self of
the broad Meadow industrial estate
sorry presentation is slightly slow
[Music]
oh the
I imagine it will skip about five slides
in one game now
maybe if we escape
no it appears to have Frozen
excellent
okay I'll just continue to describe the
scheme so uh the scheme is the site is
is approximately a one hectare site and
it is located within the northern
boundary of the Estuary access is from
the a381 so which is the main road
coming into timmouth and
um the scheme at the moment that oh
crashed out of global
oh should we connect to mine
I don't know why it's done it
[Music]
is
apologies members um our connection to
the remote computer in the office has uh
collapsed so it'll just take us one
moment to get reconnected
[Music]
foreign
so this is the site location plan so
this is the red line for the site so
this is where all development could take
place within the red line uh if
permission were to be granted and what
you can see is this is the junction that
you'll probably be familiar with which
is the a381 junction with the broad
Meadow industrial estate and then this
is the access bridge over into the site
this is the mainline Railway the um the
train line and then you enter the site
and for members that took part in the
site visit you're probably familiar that
you enter the site and you're a slightly
raised platform and then you go around
and the access road curves round back on
itself as you enter the site you come
around into the site this way
uh you may note that the applicant does
not actually have control of the entire
site there is a bit of land which I
understand is within control Southwest
water
okay so this is the existing site plan
we've got a series of existing buildings
on the site and members will probably be
familiar that the site is currently used
for boat storage as well
so there's sort of two main bodies of
buildings here and here
um and yeah let's move on to the aerial
photograph of the site which quite
clearly illustrates that we've got the
boat storages uh takes place across most
of the site with the main two bodies of
buildings
members may have seen in the officer
report there is reference to the
non-designated Heritage asset within the
site and that is located in within this
body of buildings on the right hand side
you can also see there's the slipway on
the East sorry on the western part of
the site at the moment it is actually
proposed to install a second slipway to
the eastern part of the site which would
be located over here
this is the proposed site plan for the
development if it were to go ahead you
would have four large blocks of
buildings within the site and there's
four blocks of buildings three would be
comprised of residential accommodation
and would one would be comprised of the
commercial floor space
this would be the commercial floor space
building and these three here would be
the residential
in addition we have the 16 units of
holiday accommodation and they would
resemble Beach huts and they would be
located on the Far Eastern and Western
sides of the site
so you would enter the site this way in
the same manner you would then be met
with the car park the car park is a
two-story [ __ ] block so there is in fact
car parking underneath this level as
well
and then you would go down a slight
slope you would have access to the back
of the commercial units here and you
would have access to the dwellings
if you went the other way you would
again go round and down in the same
manner as existing you would pass by the
beach huts and you would also pass by
what the applicant has proposed as an
area of public open space green
infrastructure the exact design of that
space has not been considered that would
be left to condition if the application
was recommended for approval
um but you can see that it would be
located here it has a slightly unusual
uh section protruding out to the left
that is to reflect the levels of the
site you would have to walk along a
raised footway in order to get to the
raised area of space
and then if I move on to this plan this
plan basically is is not actually the
most up-to-date plan because it doesn't
show the green infrastructure but it is
quite an effective illustration of the
way development would proceed so you can
see that the Remain the boot storage
you can see the holiday units on either
side and the sea wall which will be
built around the site
which would entirely cover the site
apart from obviously where you've got
the slipway and then this would be the
new slip way on the Eastern side
you can see the car parking here this
would be the bin store
this is the commercial block the
industrial block with the five proposed
industrial units at ground floor with
the office floor space above it and then
you can see the nine residential
dwellings they would comprise townhouse
style development so they would be
dwelling houses they wouldn't be flats
and they would have parking at ground
floor level and then go up to the living
accommodation above
um yeah so that's the main features of
the site we've also got this bit of the
site here in the middle which would be
the industrial bin store and the boat
wash down area
okay so we'll look at what the buildings
will actually look like so
um this is the westernmost residential
block you remember I said there was
three different residential blocks was
the westernmost of them
and this is essentially a terrorist but
stepped terrorists to reflect the
arrangement of the site
so this would be the appearance of the
buildings and you can see this Southern
elevation would most likely be the most
visually prominent obviously if you're
looking at the site from ringmore or
Sheldon you'll look at that elevation so
this is kind of the most prominent you
could say if you were looking at the
site
from down the Estuary then you would be
looking at
at this elevation so the west elevation
you can see on these elevation drawings
there's like dotted lines at the top it
says 1900 oh sorry 1908 that is actually
a reduction in height that was proposed
by the applicant during the course of
the application to respond to objections
from the landscape officer that the
buildings were too big
okay
um if we look at the floor plans just to
get an idea for what the buildings would
comprise so these would be townhouse
style development you would have
bookends of larger buildings with a
smaller building in the middle so the
northernmost and southernmost building
on this block would be a five-bedroom
property with a study and the one in the
middle which is a bit smaller would be
four bedrooms
okay
then we look at the Eastern residential
blocks so again it's a broadly similar
style of development just the alignment
is slightly different so we've got more
of a conventional Terrace
um
quite similar to the
of a block
and again the floor the floor plans are
very similar they're not exactly the
same but they are a very similar
approach with the garage and the parking
the basement and then rising up to the
living accommodation
foreign
this is the commercial building so this
would be the biggest building within the
site
as you can see you've got five
industrial units at ground floor level
and then you go up to the office floor
space above
and this would be like the central spine
with like the stairs and utilities Etc
um and you can see again the reduction
in height that was proposed of the
building in response to the landscape
officer's objection
and this would be the floor plan for the
industrial units so it would be five
um spaces that I assume would be
available for rent or sale and they
would have access from both sides
and then the office floor plan there's
not really much to the office floor plan
it's open flexible space it could be
subdivided into smaller office units or
it could be a rented I assume also
assumed rented
um at um as large a floor plates
depending on market demand
and then these are the beach Huts so
these would be individual units of
tourist accommodation suitable for
overnight stays quite small just
comprising a kitchenette facility a
bathroom and a small living space
okay I'll go through the site photos now
so this is the site as it looks from
ringmore this Photograph was taken from
the Strand in ringmore if you're
familiar with that road
yep so you can see you've got the
existing boat store that's the a381
behind this is obviously the edge of the
industrial estate
another fish of the site but this time
without zoomed in on the camera
so this is the view of the site from the
timmouth Sheldon bridge this is an
important view because the Tim the
Sheldon bridges are grade 2 listed
building as set not building and
um
you'll be familiar from having read the
officer report officer's consideration
of the Heritage issues that it is
considered that less than substantial
harm would arise to the Heritage asset
if this scheme were to go ahead
um
this is the site access so it's quite
narrow it's not suitable for two
vehicles it's it's only wide enough to
have one vehicle and a pedestrian access
okay so as you enter the site you recall
that I spoke about this ramp that comes
back down and back around that is the
ramp that is the Southwest water
substation which Falls outside the
applicant's ownership and then this area
of land being used to store materials at
the moment is where the green
infrastructure space would be proposed
which would be at a raised platform
[Music]
at the moment this again this part of
the site is being used first the storage
of materials but this would be dedicated
to Boat Storage
this gives you quite a nice view of the
listed Bridge The View towards timmouth
and also the public right-of-way so
um the members may be familiar I don't
know there is a public right of way
which runs along here it's known as
footpath nine it is only accessible at
low tide
uh there has been discussion about this
footpath forming part of the Teen
Estuary Trail in the future but that is
not confirmed and that hasn't been a
planning application submitted for that
part of the tea industry Trail yet
this is the
um right hand side block of buildings
the Eastern block of buildings within
the site so you can see
um the what has been described as the
non-designated Heritage asset which is
these brick arches the Limestone and
this wall is essentially left over from
the former gasworks use of the site so
historically originally the site was a
Gas Works it has been used for lots of
different things recently more recently
but uh the reason the site was there
originally was as a Gas Works
and then this is the Western block of
buildings within the site at the moment
so this is just the western part of the
site where the site ends this is where
you would have the beach Huts in the new
sea wall
so obviously
um the rubble Etc and the part of the
foreshore would be lost and you would
have a wall in place with the space made
up by new made ground
again it's user-based storage at the
moment
the final image this shows um
essentially the existing slipway and and
a view of the site within the setting of
Sheldon behind it
okay so I'm just going to briefly
explain what the officer recommendation
is and the reasons for the office of
recommendation
[Music]
so the officer recommendation is one of
refusal there are seven specific reasons
for refusal
there are
um substantive reasons for refusal and
Technical reasons for refusal
substantive reasons for refusal by which
I mean reasons for refusal which
couldn't be overcome by the applicant
without a fundal fundamental revision of
the scheme
there are then technical reasons for
refusal these are matters which likely
could be overcome by the applicant was
additional information to be submitted a
legal agreement submitted that type of
thing so
we have particular concern obviously
with the substantive reasons for refusal
the technical reasons have to be there
but could be overcome
so in this location in planning policy
terms is located outside the assessment
boundary for timmouth members will
likely be familiar but that means that
the local plan does not support new
housing in this location
it does support new affordable housing
in this location because it is adjacent
to the settlement boundary
but we do not have affordable housing
proposed here or housing would be Market
housing
so we have conflict with the local plan
in terms of the provision of new housing
in this location
we also have new office floor space
proposed here
it is acceptable to have new office for
space in the countryside under the local
plan as long as compliance with certain
policies is met
however if you read the criteria of the
policies in particular the rural
employment policy
yes the Royal employment policy does
apply even though we are adjacent to the
settlement you if you assess the
criteria of that policy you'll see that
those criteria are not met
and the reason the criteria are not
meant principally is because of the
designation of this site as the
undeveloped Coast
the undeveloped Coast is a policy which
applies to quite a lot of the district
obviously the our Coastal district and
to the both the Estuary environment and
the coastal environment
uh it runs quite far up the teen Estuary
and it includes this site
now obviously this is a Brownfield site
it's a previously developed site but it
does form part of that undeveloped Coast
policy designation the policy therefore
does apply and we are required to assess
the scheme against compliance with that
policy
the policy is quite strict it sets out
that only certain types of development
will be acceptable in the location
Marine related development is acceptable
so officers do not have concern with the
industrial Boatyard use of this site and
we do not have concern with the
industrial Boatyard part of the
application as proposed
but there is concern with the scale of
the buildings in this location the fact
that they are particularly tall narrow
buildings with small Footprints which
increases the impression of scale and
height and the obtrusiveness of the
development within the Airstream and we
also have concerns that
the development will lead to significant
harm to the landscape character of the
area
so those are the substantive reasons for
refusal
we then oh sorry we then moved to the
technical reasons for refusal
so heritage
has been given as a technical reason for
refusal now it would be possible to
overcome the Heritage concerns here
there's concern with the loss of the
non-designated Heritage asset within the
site
which is that that wall that I showed
you so the wool um is proposed for
demolition
as officers we would expect that the
development would be derived from uh its
local context any items of any things of
value within the site which could be
preserved or replicated through the
development to give a sense of place and
a sense of context to the development
but obviously the non-designated
Heritage asset is proposed for
demolition
and then we have the setting of The
timoth Sheldon Bridge which is a grade
two listed asset the applicant's own
Heritage advisor Heritage consultant I
should say has advised that the scheme
would result in less than substantial
harm to that asset
just to talk you through that a little
bit less than substantial harm is a
phrase that's used within the mppf the
national planning policy framework if
there is any harm at all
we are required to give great weight to
that harm
and to require clear and convincing
justification if you accept the harm and
approve the development
we consider that the Heritage concern
could be overcome through a redesign of
the scheme which would incorporate the
non-designated Heritage asset into the
scheme and would reduce the scale of the
buildings on the site
there's the HRA payment which is a
requirement because we have some
European sites within our district we
have the accessory Doris Warren again we
do not have sufficient payment so that
has given us a reason for refusal could
quite easily be overcome by the
applicant
we have ecological harm
so
this site lies within the County
wildlife site the whole of the Estuary
is a County wildlife site
we are within the SG environment here
we're in flood zone 3 so we're at the
highest risk of flooding
this scheme is
proposes a sea wall around the entire
site
and the sea wall is proposed to require
an additional 1 000 square meters of
land take from the estuary
that will involve the loss of a not
quite a thousand square meters of
intertidal habitat
uh members who attended the site visit
may remember we discussed this issue so
um
the reason for refusal refers to an
unmitigated loss of
838 square meters of intertidal habitat
that is not 1 000 meters the reason this
is not is because the applicant has
proposed on the sea wall
to have essentially lots of uh the
design of the sea wall would be
um have lots of small holes and
indentations and features within it
which would to some extent replicate the
intertidal habitat
so there is some mitigation for the loss
of intertidal habitat but we remain with
838 square meters
of loss
and we do not have any mitigation in
place for that
we also have concern with impact on the
native oyster again these are technical
reasons they are things that could be
overcome by the applicant
immunity for future of occupiers is a
concern
so if we look at the site layout
here we are so what you can see is that
you've got the in the commercial block
in the middle and then immediate which
is here and then immediately adjacent to
it you've got the dwellings and there's
really they are in very close proximity
you also have the residential uh holiday
accommodation over here and to get to
that one would have to park here come
around or park underneath here and
travel across the site
we have concerns with the workability of
this Arrangement is it really the best
layout and will it preserve immunity for
future occupiers and this has been
considered by the applicant but we
remain concerned with the impact of
introducing new residential uses here
onto what is a Boatyard space
and the impact that might have then on
the future operation of the Boatyard we
do not want to entail the operations of
the Boatyard this we want to support the
operations of the Boatyard we don't want
to be in a position where we are having
to limit the operations of the Boatyard
from a noise perspective or in hours of
operation perspective when essentially
this is a Boatyard space and that is the
type of that is the part of the
development that we wish to support
because it complies with policy and then
finally we get to the green
infrastructure so because the green
infrastructure wasn't thought about from
the start it was a change that was made
during the course of the application
it's this little bit of uh blue land
as shown on
this plan which is very much a little
island of uh public open space what we
would like to see is a soft Landscaping
strategy for the site which provides a
green environment where the the built
environment is integrated with the green
environment
so we don't just have an island of green
within otherwise Urban side
um there's also concern that certain
elements of the policy have not been met
that would need to be met through a
financial obligation that hasn't been
proposed by the applicant so again the
forms part of the reason for refusal
um so yeah so that is all of the reasons
for refusal this site is quite complex
there's a lot of different constraints
applicable to the site
um so they're happy to take any
questions that you might have and um
we'll draw the uh presentation to an end
there
okay
thank you very much Jennifer
um
so I'm not seeing any indication that
there's questions at the moment so I
would like to move on to the next person
to speak I beg your pardon
could could I just ask what what is
going to be to the south of the
buildings in in that area that is beige
yeah there yeah so the majority of the
space of this site as you can see with
all the boats as shown on the drawing
that's just proposed to be retained as
boat storage space
right so so that will be tarmac or I
don't know what the final surface
material would be for that it hasn't
hasn't been agreed through the
development it would need to be agreed
before development procedure and and the
bit between the boat storage and the
buildings what will that be please
there's no there's no particular
proposal for that bit of land one
assumes it would be used as circulation
access space in order to get to the
holiday accommodation that's on that Far
Side
um at the moment the site quite clears
the resembles this you know there isn't
a clear demarcation and let's assume
that that same Arrangement will continue
okay thanks
okay
um not seeing any other indications now
apologies
um we will now move on to
um the objector who wishes to speak and
it's a Joe cumbly hope I'm pronouncing
that right if you'd like to come forward
and you're going to have 10 minutes to
speak from the moment you start so
can you make sure that the microphone is
is thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
I appreciate the opportunity to speak at
the committee and I'm here to speak in
opposition to the proposed development
I note that this is an application that
has been thoroughly considered by
teambridge planning officers in their
very detailed report of the 25th of
October and I wholeheartedly endorse the
officer's recommendation that you refuse
permission
I anticipate that the applicant will
seek to persuade you today that this
development is largely about supporting
local businesses however in response I
would simply point out that only one of
the buildings they propose would be for
commercial use as opposed to 16 units of
holiday accommodation and nine open
market houses
there would be no affordable housing
built on this site at all this is
therefore primarily a Housing
Development on a highly desirable
Riverside plot
turning now to the report as the officer
notes the principle of this development
specifically the provision of open
market dwellings and new office floor
space in this location is contrary to
the team bridge local development plan
specifically policies s21a s22 en2 and
EC3
the council can currently demonstrate a
five-year housing land Supply
accordingly there is no overriding need
to secure residential development on the
site
notwithstanding this the Tilted balance
at paragraph 11 of the national planning
policy framework would not be engaged
even if a five-year housing land Supply
could not be demonstrated because harm
to designated Heritage assets has been
identified
this is confirmed at footnote 7 of the
nppf
furthermore it is clear that the very
viability of this proposal is in
question
the council's viability assessors
concluded the overall scheme to be
unviable and your offices in turn are
concerned that the scheme is
undeliverable
officers are of the opinion are set out
in paragraph 8.5 of their report but it
is highly unlikely that it would ever be
built in its present form additional
development of the most valuable parts
of the scheme would likely be necessary
in order to improve viability
If This Were to be the case any future
revisions would surely lead the
applicant to seek an increase in the
provision of open market housing on the
site which is confirmed as being in
conflict with the development plan
policies
in terms of design I firmly support the
officer's conclusion that the
development would neither protect nor
enhance the undeveloped Coast or
character of the of the locality in fact
the inappropriate scale and sheer
magnitude of this development would have
a wholly unacceptable impact on the
landscape character and appearance of
the riverscape and Coastline and so I'm
afraid represents poor and unsympathetic
Design
this is again clearly contrary to
adopted policy
in addition I fully agree with your
reporting officer that the development
will harm the significance of important
heritage heritage assets and that there
are no overriding public benefits having
regard to the relevant tests here set
out at paragraphs 199 200 and 202 of the
nppf
the nppf requires that any harm to the
significance of a designated Heritage
asset requires clear and convincing
justification
this duty to protect and enhance such
assets is mirrored in policy en5 of the
local plan
section 66 of the planning listed
buildings and conservation areas act
1990 places the duty on local planning
authorities to pay special regard to the
desirability of preserving listed
buildings and their settings
in this case the applicant's own
Heritage appraisal and impact assessment
noteworthily only submitted to the
council two months ago concludes at
Section 5 that the proposed new
development would be quite prominent in
views from designated Heritage assets
where setting plays an important part in
their significance
there are areas where there clearly
would be some adverse Heritage impact
notably from the Northern end of the
Sheldon bridge where the rural view up
the Estuary would be partly blocked
resulting in some less and substantial
harm to the significance of the Heritage
asset that's the applicant's own report
your officers report agrees with the
Heritage appraisal's conclusion
confirming that less than substantial
harm would result and a paragraph 11.13
comments that from a Heritage
perspective the comprehensive
Redevelopment of this site with large
new buildings will result in a
significant change to the character of
the area
the development will dominate The View
West and up the Estuary introducing
substantial new built form onto a site
which currently reads as part of and at
the level of the Estuary environment
the significance of the bridge as the
largest built environmental structure
within the Estuary will be harmed as
will an appreciation of its attractive
open setting
in addition to the adverse impact of the
proposals on grade 2 listed Sheldon
bridge I would draw your attention also
to the impact on those Heritage assets
just across the river from the Boatyard
which are protected by the ringmore
conservation area management plan
adopted by teambridge in 2008
the plan states that ringmore occupies
an outstanding natural setting fronting
the two the Estuary of the Teen and its
most valued asset is the east facing
Estuary Frontage that projects
dramatically forward of the shoreline
this is ringmore strand a road
comprising of Eight houses five of which
are grade two listed buildings that the
applicant accepts in their own Heritage
appraisal will be affected by the
prominence of this proposed development
the ringworm plan further states that it
will always be important to consider the
impact any development proposals might
have on ringmoor's Esterline setting
particularly when viewed from the
opposite Bank the length of ringmore
Road and from the Estuary itself
members as you will be well aware
wingmore strand is almost exactly
opposite the proposed River level
development and any such view from this
of the Strand from the east from Sheldon
Bridge ringmore Road and from the
Estuary itself also encompasses a clear
view of the Riverside boat yard
it must be accepted therefore that the
setting of valuable Heritage assets
including a whole Conservation Area will
be directly and adversely affected by
these proposals
it is apparent that the applicant has
not provided clear and convincing
justification to support the proposal in
Heritage terms and I endorse your
office's conclusions that there are
insufficient public benefits to outweigh
the identified harm to the designated
Heritage assets
turning to the landscape harm resorting
from the scheme the LA the officers
report makes it clear that this is also
of considerable concern
the applicant's own landscape and visual
impact assessment concludes that the
impact to the site character would be
quote slighterverse impact to the
landscape character would be slight
moderate adverse and a moderate adverse
impact would result to visual immunity
again this is the applicant's OWN report
this is a prominent site within the teen
Estuary and despite some revision to the
scheme it is clear that the quantum and
sheer scale of the development will
adversely impact the openness and
expansive cross Estuary views which are
identified as key characteristics of the
Teen Estuary landscape character area as
confirmed within the council's landscape
character assessment
The Proposal includes a significant
number of imposing buildings which are
up to five stories in height making them
similar in height to the broad Meadow
Flats on the Hills above flat switch
members I'm sure you'll agree no one
could argue have enhanced the Estuary
environment from a landscape point of
view
it would clearly be wrong to have
buildings of this scale on the ferry
bank of the beautiful River team where
they would be at where they would
adversely dominate the riverscape when
viewed for miles around
there is no convincing argument Advanced
by the applicant that these significant
impacts to the landscape character and
undeveloped Coast should be allowed
through the granting of this application
and indeed the lack of meaningful
Landscaping proposals as part of this
scheme further adds to everyone's
concerns on this issue
there are many other concerns raised by
officers all of which I fully support I
think I'm about to run out of time
however
um in conclusion your offices have
identified that this scheme is clearly
contrary in many respects to your
adopted plan policies it is also
contrary to National policies which are
clear that the planning system should be
genuinely plan LED and it's important
particularly where there are no reasons
to otherwise do so that the plan and its
policies should be followed this key
scheme clearly sorry simply and clearly
does not follow plan policy and should
not be granted permission I therefore
respectfully request that the officer's
recommendation is supported and members
resolve to is to refuse planning
permission
thank you
thank you Miss crumbly
um should I turn this off yeah thank you
if you'd like to retake your seat thank
you
we will now move on to supporters time
to speak and I think there's been a
slight change we have Peter Stenner
coming forward first if that's right
thank you if you'd like to take a seat
you will have five minutes from the time
that you start speaking if you'd like to
switch the microphone on in front of you
members of the committee good morning
I'm the applicant for the scheme Peter
stunner my company timoth Maritime
properties limited owns and operates the
Boatyard
I grew up in timoth I went to Brookhill
school where little now stands and
attended timoth grammar school I left in
1978 starting work for the family around
the local boat hiring
fishing business
when the proprietor retired in 1982 I
bought the business and we still trade
there today employing a Boatman and
seasonal staff
in 91 myself and a good friend started
timoth Marathon Services we are still
basing team bridge and operate both
locally and nationally employing more
than 100 people the majority of which
live in teambridge
five years ago I secured the Riverside
site from Southwest water my initial
plan had been to continue using this as
a Boatyard and a repair and maintenance
facility for our own Fleet of vessels
but it soon became apparent that there
was a serious ongoing demand for
improved Boatyard facilities for local
boat owners has this plan evolved it was
clear that I could offer a unique
opportunity to give something back to
the town I have a long history with a
Boatyard and extends well over 40 years
having worked on my own boats in the old
existing buildings been involved as the
Marine superintendent during the
construction of the Southwest water
clean sweep scheme throughout the
Estuary and through the Boatyard
and now as owner and managing director
of the current Boatyard
this design has been progressed from my
wish to provide several specific
facilities to meet and enhance the needs
of the community including fledgling
businesses visitors and at the same time
secure the site for generations to come
I'm trying to give something back to the
town that I grew up in and living with
my family
given the heavy industrial history of a
site we need our proposal to address any
harmful materials which are there and
protect future users and the river as
such the scheme includes a robust
seal wall to effectually effectively
sorry encapsulate the site which will
protect it from flooding and prevent any
potential Leach of contaminants back
into the river
this has been agreed with the
environmental agency and gained from the
demanding requirements
so and gains permission from the
demanding requirements of the Marine
management organization the MMO our
neighbors the crown Estates sold us part
of their River funders for the purpose
of this regeneration and are fully
behind the scheme
I have experience of a delicate balance
for small businesses between premises
and profit what we are proposing would
see the construction of proposed built
units which will be occupied
by the maritime businesses Who currently
trade from the site but at a price which
allows them to grow and thrive
there is a distinct lack of office
versus facilities in timoth and the
surrounding area The Proposal addresses
that need
to effectively provide a subsidy for the
very substantial costs of building the
vital sea wall and assist with keeping
the commercial elements of the project
at a level affordable to local
businesses it was decided to include an
element of residential accommodation
with you within the overall project
this residential element has been
designed to sit comfortably here and in
that context was noted by the council's
landscape office at that quote the
design responds positively to the
context of tinmouth and undoubtedly
brings benefits unquote
the idea of mixed-use residential and
boating Services is a proven Concept in
Dartmouth exmouth totmes Falmouth and
Salcombe amongst other places
the river teen is very much a poor
relation when compared to other parts
ports sorry along the South Devon Coast
I know this to be chosen my other
companies worked and continues to work
in most of them this scheme will start
to redress the balance
given the success of similar schemes
elsewhere in the district
it was decided to include tourist
accommodation in the form of beach Huts
given the changing face of a tourism
industry in a lack of appropriate
accommodation close to the river team
advice from industry experts with whom
we have consulted suggest that this
would offer a very popular facility
before approaching the planus the
proposals were discussed with local
community groups to ensure they were
supportive of the overall plan these
included included local residents town
and District councilors the harbor
Authority the team Fisherman's
Waterman's Association oyster and muscle
fishermen from the river team the crown
Estates and Boatyard users
the scheme was home to ensure that it
met their wishes and requirements
and with a leap of faith and support
from you the committee I can convert
this run-down Brownfield site into an
area that brings significant benefits to
one of the poorest Wards of teambridge
and establish a facility for future
Generations
[Music]
you tell me thank you very much thank
you
can I call on uh Martha grecos please
I hope I pronounced that right
please take a seat
if you'd like to switch on the
microphone and again you have five
minutes when you start
good morning my name is Martha grecos
and I'm the Barrister representing the
applicant here today with regards to
their proposed application
as you heard from the applicant himself
there are many benefits this scheme will
bring including the positive impact for
the business on site through improved
facilities and affordable rent a
positive income on local tourism a
positive impact on housing Supply and of
course a positive impact in terms of
construction of a sea wall to protect
from flooding which has been approved by
the environment agency in the Marine
Maritime organization
the scheme is supported by local and
wider Community to date around 64
supporting statements have been received
by the officers and only about 22
objections most recently you will have
received supporting letters from the
following people and organizations one
the British Marine Southwest
which is the trade Association body for
the leisure marine sector emphasizing
the need for sure site development the
safeguards Marine related Services
secondly the inshore fisheries and
conservation Authority which has no
objection to this application as all its
concerns with regards to the shellfish
shell fisheries and possible water
quality issues have all been addressed
through the construction of the
surrounding wall and measures to contain
any silt and potential pollutants
thirdly tenderness of the Riverside
Boatyard who want and need high quality
modern facilities to support their
business
fourthly Knight Frank on behalf of the
crown estate who highlighted that the
cell of the areas of the foresha are
rare but the crown estate knew of the
proposals and decided to sell as a
gesture of support for the investment
and development of the site and fifthly
a local fisherman who supports the
scheme for the much-needed employment of
local people
it is fair to say that this scheme has
not been easy to bring forward the
initial planning officer worked with the
applicant towards a positive outcome
however with the replacement officer
there's been a change in the approach
due to the lack of Engagement and delays
which have prevented the applicant from
bringing forward a fully rounded
proposal for example it took six weeks
for the council to validate the
application there has been a lack of
input from conversation officer and
Landscape officer which has led to a
failure to comprehend the contest of the
report and the planning officer refused
to review additional reports submitted
in effect predetermining this
application already but stating that it
will be refused even though further
documents were still been submitted and
the applicant's team was awaiting
responses the camp a planning committee
reports before you today was even
written up in advance
notwithstanding this we believe that the
proposals can be given consent and that
any concerns can be ameliorated through
the imposition of planning conditions on
the permission or planning obligations
in the section 106 agreements
for example the applicant is willing to
make a financial contribution to Green
Space
um
to make a financial screen space
off-site the applicant is willing to
agree to a phasing plan which it
dictates of the housings and Beach Huts
can be constructed once the other
buildings and if the infrastructure have
been completed and the applicant is
willing to pay a greater habitats
regulations assessment fee to cover the
beach huts none have been asked or
proposed by the council and if they were
the applicant would have agreed to this
it is also worth stressing that the
council and as a result the local
community will receive in the region of
550 000 of community infrastructure Levy
at nine dwellings towards the council's
five-year land Supply and a tax counts
council tax revenue in excess of ten
thousand pounds per annum so that's 550
000 pounds of sale and ten thousand
pounds per Ammon in terms of tax I
therefore urge you to resolve to Grant
consent for their schemes to say your
officer highlighted one substantial
reasons and two technically reasons and
the actual uh objector said that these
cannot be ameliorated however this is a
balancing exercise that you are allowed
to do given the benefits that we have
highlighted and as you know there will
always be some change when a proposal
comes forward but there is nowhere where
it was stated that these were so adverse
as the objecture claims through their
choice of her own words
secondly in terms of technical reasons I
already said highlighted quite clearly
how this can be no can become and even
your officer yourself said these can be
overcome by the applicant I therefore
see that there is no reason why you
should be refusing the application today
thank you
thank you very much
right we also have Ward members with us
who wish to speak I believe councilor
Jeffrey is your first to come along
you'd like to come to the front please
foreign
thank you
thank you good morning everyone
colleagues I'm here before you today as
war council of West tinmouth
the area where the application is
proposed
West timmouth and the gateway to the
town is dilapidated and run down not the
entryway to the beautiful tourist
destination it deserves to be
my ward has historically been a mix of
industrial and residential and
improvements are greatly needed to the
area in order for it to thrive
business plays a vital role in the
economic development and wealth of such
areas success in business translates to
the economic well-being of its residents
through job creation and offering
improved quality of life for Citizens
all of which have been outlined in this
application
indeed Riverside boat yards application
not only Builds on these requirements
its strategic Vision safeguards the
delivery of marine related Services
preventing relocation and transference
of wealth outside of teambridge
TMS themselves are local as we've heard
have not only a long standing in the
community in which they wish to make
these vast improvements but bring a
wealth of expertise in building
successful developments in Marine
environments
their vision and values underpin the
projects
sorry their vision and values underpin
the projects they get involved in both
in the UK and Europe they have led the
field in Marine and civil construction
flood defenses Harbors marinas and many
more
some of the prestigious work they've
undertaken is too long to list but
includes timoth Seawall oxen Cove and
Brixton Isle of Man Marina Portland port
a network rail Chippenham
in working closely with developers and
investors with this level of expertise
and shows the best for all of our
communities
the comments from the public in the
application and from those I've spoken
with in preparation for today regarding
the development are hugely supportive as
we've heard
to date the application has has revised
and updated their viability plan
biodiversity information approved by the
environment agency carbon reduction plan
and acoustic report
among other things it is hoped that full
considerations should be given to the
applicant across all aspects of the
application and what it will bring
they're a definable public benefits
affordable industrial units and office
space taking account of smes with
currently nowhere to go
the plans include improving the current
usage environment as we've heard such as
a longer and safer slip way removal of
contaminants and provision of a raised
foot way to connect the town linking to
the proposals for the teen Estuary Trail
those reference to how the dwellings
aspects will work alongside the
industrial element of the site and the
applicant has demonstrable expertise in
developing such such as in bricksome
due to the nature of the scheme the
current boat yard is not fit for purpose
and there are no other available sites
that this development could occupy with
access to the water
developments such as these provide
valuable Services products and tax
income that debt direct directly
contribute to the health of the
community they also provide jobs
strengthening their economic health of
each Community where the business is
based
the Riverside development will
contribute vital employment to encourage
the success of West himmoth
and team bridge as a whole encouraging a
sense of civic pride and investment in
where people live
a knock-on effect that will bring a
Rejuvenation to an area that desperately
needs it
the viability study outlines 18 million
of investment into the area as we've
heard and it is worth noting that West
timmouth is ranked one of the most
deprived areas of the country currently
in the top third for levels of
deprivation
it is impressive to note that the
applicants shares the concerns of crown
Estates whose historically do not make
sales of their Acquisitions lightly
Crown Estates in their latter of support
detail that they have sold the land
due to the works proposed within this
development offering a long-term
solution to improve subsidence and
remove contamination making safe the
area for long-term benefit
a large amount of sale linked to the
development of the Riverside Boatyard
could be used to further maintain the
much needed infrastructure for the area
supporting services which are essential
to the good health and benefit of the
community so it will not just be the
private Enterprise profiting but that of
the Council on the behalf of the
community
regeneration is directly related to the
economic health and well-being of the
people in that locality
profitable businesses Drive economic
health which translates to a better
quality of life for the community the
application outlines the expertise and
due diligence in relating in relation to
water quality flood defense and longer
term impact on sustainability
businesses on the nearby Broadmeadow
estate and timoth chamber have indicated
they are welcoming the development in
bringing improvements and jobs to the
area
investments in regenerations such as
Riverside Boatyard boost economic
Revenue directly and positively affect
the health quality in life and
purchasing power of residents in the
local community
vitally important during these turbulent
times
the project presents cell monies of 550k
as we've just had and an opportunity to
work with the business prepared to
invest in one of the most deprived
communities in teambridge
an opportunity to drive economic growth
for generations to come
a positive narrative for the future of
our currently struggling Marine economy
which requires much needed investment
applications like these need to be
looked at in the context of the current
fiscal environment and economic downturn
impacts of which are predicted to be
long lasting and set to get worse as the
UK and Europe seek to drive down
consumption
the applicant has developed a strong
relationship with South Devon College a
stakeholder of TDC whose Marine
education has been one of the fastest
growing areas of late
the relationship is set to flourish as
the applicant seeks to include at the
Boatyard classroom space for South Devon
college and a route to employment
through apprenticeships
demonstrating the applicant's
willingness to work within policies such
as the recovery plan and alongside our
stakeholders to prove provide meaningful
local opportunities and growth for the
sector
we are all aware how employers and
business owners are increasingly
struggling to retain productivity due to
the rising costs of fuel and utilities
which in turn put a strain on people
having to cover their costs of traveling
to work
priority should be given to developments
like Riverside whose employment and
investment proposals are focused on
local expertise and job creation
saving the consumer long term but also
investing in local trades in the
immediate future who would be procured
to realize the development keeping
wealth in teambridge this is more than
just an application it is an opportunity
to weather the storm of recession
to have widespread support from such a
broad scope of agencies on an
application which is not only impressive
but has the community and users at its
heart presents an opportunity to work
cohesively
a positive outcome for this application
today will ensure the investment is
primed to create a lasting positive
impact on the community job security and
the economy for generations to come
thank you
thank you councilor Jeffries
councilor Cox you wanted to speak on
this item as the other award member
thank you very much if you'd like to
switch on the microphone thank you I
think it's all been said I think I want
to determine my brother Tim is a harbor
commissioner just not not that's an
interest but to make that clear from the
beginning
um
but if we get to the bottom of planning
it we ought to look at the preamble to
the Town and Country planning act and
that's basically says an act to provide
for uh uh setting out planning for the
public interest now this application is
massively in the public interest it's in
the interest of teambridge it's
definitely an interest of West Timbers
Peter is a well-known local entrepreneur
even when I'm on the litter picks I see
him mending the shed he's not gone to
his head you know this is a massive
investment in tinlove and in teambridge
and we really need to do that we have
bro that is by no means is that an
undeveloped Coast that is an old Gas
Works
with a Brownfield site with the
contaminated land and therefore and it's
a Boatyard now so really we should be
supporting this application there is uh
people used to live on site uh when it
was Gas Works
um we have a shortage of holiday of
holiday accommodation in um in
teambridge we know that so actually
that's helpful so we should support this
application it represents a good good
news story for tinmouth and teambridge
as a planning application but it opens
up it's the it opens up the door to
Regeneration projects the walkways
between polysteps and Riverside would
enable the psychopath if it ever gets uh
gets built to move go across the road
into straight into the town by a walkway
between Riverside uh through the arch in
Sheldon bridge and along the public
footpath on the docks so this massive
regeneration possibility that come from
giving permission to this application
we'd perhaps we were mistaken to have
not had to had this as a undeveloped
Coast but it is an industrial site it
always has been it has been since the
19th century
um so we should support this application
it does the benefits to timoth and to
team which are so great that it's worth
ignoring the plan we have we have um
with te3 we've expanded the air into the
undeveloped Coast
um moved made that area larger so we
have done this before we have moved into
the undeveloped Coast where there's
we've been shown there is a benefit
there's a massive benefit here and I
would just have to point out that
Sheldon bridge is not the entire
structure of British golden bridge is
not a two stylistic building it's either
in the shoulder they should the stone
end uh built with slave slave trade
money um it's uh is either is either end
of the bridge that are in fact listed
the main part of the bridge is in fact
um not not listed so it's not not the
whole bridge and if you were to be at
the end of Sheldon bridge and you were
to look to the east rather than the West
you would see a Boatyard owned by
Cambridge District Council called
polysteps I mean it's I'm sorry some of
these arguments have been ridiculous
when you look at what's already there so
I think we should support this
application it would tidy up this site
it's not in Peter's interests to make an
untidy or on a a carbuncle on the side
of the river nothing is is higher than
the highest point of the old Gas Works
which you can see in the minutes of the
Town Council the heights
um uh so I think we should support this
application though it goes against our
policy because if you open your eyes and
look at it it's already a industrial
site it would just be making it more of
an industrial style and you know as I
say we do need that we do need the
holiday accommodation so that's a
welcome development
um
as I say a load of other potential
benefits are going to come to Tim with
we have the worst polluted Rose one of
the worst polluted roads in Christendom
in the Benton Park Road by by opening
the key to the walkway we could we could
move to help deal with the pollution on
that road so I would hope that members
would support
uh accept this application uh possibly
add conditions but please support it it
has the support of all of tinmouth it
really does and it's it's um it's a
massive investment it's a massive vote
of confidence in teambridge and we
should we should take this with both
hands
thank you councilor Cox if you'd like to
switch thank you
bring you in just one moment
yeah I thought yeah
yeah okay no that's fine yeah
um I note your
um your uh wanted to come in can I first
of all can we go through the the
speakers at this point
um and look at the the site inspection
um Tim asked the the members of the site
Inspection Team to also give their
points of view please I know councilor
petherick councilor kurzwell and
councilor Parker I think you all three
of you were in that
that point
okay all right
um
I'm also informed that planning officers
wish to to make some comments as well so
address two factual inaccuracies that
were raised in the second war councilors
comments about the listed building first
of all the list of building listed asset
I should say which is the bridge it does
comprise the full extent of the bridge
but members may be familiar from driving
across the bridge that the fabric of the
bridge of most of the fabric of the
bridge is of modern construction so the
historic fabric is only at either end
that doesn't mean that the whole of the
structure isn't listed the whole of the
structure is a listed asset and we are
legally obliged to consider the setting
of the listed asset as a whole and then
secondly the public right-of-way so
there's a suggestion that this scheme
will in some way facilitate or um allow
the teen Estuary Trail to come forward
that that is not the case this scheme
will not preclude the delivery of the
Teen Estuary Trail it will have no
impact on the delivery of the teenage
tutorial when the application was
originally submitted the applicant did
propose to provide a public right-of-way
across the bridge through the site to
footpath nine which is a possible
intended route of the Teen S2 Trail
however during the course of the
application that offer was withdrawn so
we no longer have a proposal for a
public right-of-way through him that's
not to say that that one couldn't be
negotiated in the future by Devon County
Council and that would be done
separately most likely separately to the
planning regime in it through a private
agreement
but to say that this scheme will
facilitate the tea Industries right
that's not actually correct
okay
thank you um just for that Clarity
um could I ask
um I don't know who wants to go first
from the site Inspection Team councilor
pedrick you've raised your hands first
if
yes
we were there absolutely fine thank you
thank you
foreign
yes I I attended the site visit on the
4th of August it was an interesting site
visit and I've come away from there with
three areas of concern
um I'm happy to elaborate on those three
areas now if you like Madam chair
absolutely fine okay thank you there
have been a number of references made to
the construction of the sea wall this
site is being partially is partially
recrimed Land from the sea over many
decades I guess and the sea wall will go
beyond the existed the boundary of the
existing land
now this though there is a figure in the
Bible that the biodiversity officers
report which is section 12.8
which advises that there will be a loss
of intertidal area of 1010 square meters
because of the construction of the wall
but however the war will have sort of
Little Forks that everybody built into
it which will encourage sea life to
attach itself to it but there's still
going to be a loss of 838 square meters
of of uh Estuary now I've done some
calculations because it's difficult to
visualize what 838 square meters looks
like but I'll give you an example a
doubles tennis court
is 23.77 meters long
10.97 meters wide
that equals
260.75 square meters
if you divide the 803 so 838 square
meters by the size of a doubles tennis
court you will get in 3.21 tennis courts
so that's just shows you how much of the
Estuary we're going to lose and the the
detrimental effect that that will have a
substantial effect it will have on
marine life
on the estuary
a second point is
excuse me if I'm thumping through
paperwork here
is regarding over development
um the well some form of development
could be appropriate for this site and
and I hope that we see something there
The Proposal is a gross over dip
relevant for what is highly visible
highly visible location from the Teen
estuary
aside from the hype which is going to be
quite considerable the style is
ill-fitting for this location and I feel
that it would be inappropriate my third
concern is regarding the highways
report
now the the higher rate report refers to
a survey that was carried out on the
[Music]
2nd of November 2020 I mean we were in
the in the depths of covid at that time
and not many people were traveling uh
the highways appreciated this this was
also done on a Tuesday a second of which
is quite a quiet day I mean I would
approach it to sit down on a Friday but
it was done on a Tuesday
and the highways realized that perhaps
this wasn't perhaps accurate an
indication of the volume of traffic
flowing past that area so they took into
account some figures from January 2018.
uh now we're looking at sort of figures
for the depths of winter and not
necessarily at peak times during the
tourist season during sort of July and
August
there's also a reference in the report
that there have only been five slight
collisions reported by the police in the
vicinity well that was absolutely right
up until the 1st of August when there
was a fatality there a motorcyclist was
killed there that was at the junction of
Newfoundland Road and also Bishops
Dayton Road where this actual survey was
carried out
[Music]
I I I've I have grave concerns as I say
about the access to the site from the
traffic lights I have used it myself
um not not recently and I've found it if
you particularly if you're telling your
trailer it is a difficult one to get
into
in view of the the sort of the the
rather inaccurate sort of figures for
the for the the traffic survey I I once
again I have to express concerns about
the accuracy of the survey thank you
thank you councilor Patrick are there
any other members of the site Inspection
Team would like to make comments
councilor Park you you went first yeah
that's fine right thank you
thank you very much yeah my comments are
based purely and simply on the site
meeting that we had I'd like to
compliment Jennifer on our presentation
it was most thorough and detailed thank
you very much for that
um
it's this big question where do you
start or finish with this proposal
there's so many factors and no no doubt
as we've already heard there's many
different views to be considered
my comments at this time are centered on
my initial thoughts and I know some of
them have been overtaken now
they're based on my own observations the
officer's explanation and questions
posed by authorized attendees at the
meeting
in my opinion pressure whether intended
or not at the site meeting by a large
number of persons thought to be Town
Council Representatives was a little
regrettable
this is very detailed and complex
proposal incorporating many mixed use
aspects which are very rare when
constructed together when you're talking
about the large open market Residential
Properties the workshops industrial
Office Space Holiday accommodation 60
car parking I can go I could go on and
on but are all these possible on such a
constrained site
points that concern me where the access
and egress onto the site from the 381
near the traffic lights at Morrisons and
furthermore the bridge across the
railway line in the ownership of network
rail
the right of way of it and its condition
also the linkage from the site into the
town itself
then a new slipway being constructed and
the vicinity of some of the holiday
units to part of this slipway
and the use of the public in accessing
these holiday units
and the large four and five bedroom
homes are a worry to me
then you add in the office space and if
fully occupied the additional traffic
generated here on this partially
reclaimed land is a concern
they add significantly to the safety
fears on a site already widely used as
Boat Yard Works and Storage
a question is this correct area for
office space Also
it's already been mentioned but the size
and height of the office buildings and
the residential would seem to me to rise
above the railway line and the adjoining
a381 Highway perhaps this is too high
the flood rests and likely increased
flood rests from a few sources with
climate change very much in mind is a
concern
a substantial sea wall would definitely
have to be a major feature here
but there's still effectively a flood
risk in danger in place here I think
the high visibility from the Teen
Estuary the road bridge and from the
other side of the river make the site
very very prominent
a factor development of some magnitude
in my opinion the project must and does
influence the visual immunity of the
surroundings
it may seem that I have no positive
comments to be made here but
individually there are a few good
aspects I believe of the plan I like the
Innovative Divine Design of the three
blocks a residential units which
together with their positioning would be
a draw for possible residents even if
the quality of their living environment
could be questioned
their height must be questioned however
I suppose these are all proposed on an
open market basis an attempt to make the
whole tree whole scheme feasible
other elements of the scheme do have
merits when taken in isolation such as
the continued and improved Boat Boat
Yard and the business use
the investment intended on the site if
deliverable and if viable would be
welcomed and could enhance the
reputation and standing in the area
no doubt there could be a raft
conditions imposed to Aid the approval
of this application
but I feel there's a lot to overcome to
make this acceptable at this time and I
would need further convincing at this
time
and just excuse me as I said chair I do
have to leave for another appointment
thank you councilor Parker
um councilor Kurzweil did you want to
thank you
thank you chair
um first of all I would also like to
compliment our planning officer that was
a very very good presentation thank you
um this is a huge application with many
many aspects
um I can see the good in it and I can
also see the problems
for me
um the site as a whole as it is at the
moment
does certainly need some
um money put into it it's not attractive
it does need upgrading
and I can see the merits in what the
applicant is trying to do
on the other hand I can also see that
where the um the housing in itself
um
is situated and the look of them and the
height of them
um
I can see that that should be tweaked
the
the police report especially with the um
car parking where they're saying that
um you can't keep a close eye on
criminal Behavior within the the car
parking
that that is a worry where where I live
we have open areas of parking like this
not a lot but just a little and you do
get anti-social Behavior because it's
not visible
the
um access into this site
has obviously been brought up a few
times and that is also a concern
especially with the
um few accidents that have been there
and also the bridge which is not in the
ownership of the of the applicant
um
the applicant I understand from what he
said is a local guy and I do love the
idea of a local person
doing giving back to their community
in whatever way they see fit as long as
they're giving back and I do appreciate
that
I I do think that there is Merit in
pursuing this application but maybe not
as it is quite at the moment but I await
to hear from other people on this
committee before I make my views as to
whether I support it or not thank you
thank you councilor Kurzweil
um I'd like to open it up for debate I
know councilor McGregor you raised your
hand a moment ago are you happy to come
in at this point to start us off as it
were
thank you chair
yep thank you Jay
um
I the the the actual development
overlapped slightly with my own Ward
um as it timoth West ends at the traffic
lights and Bishop State award begins at
the traffic light so a considerable part
of the development overlaps with with uh
Bishop Stanton Ward
the bishop Saints Parish Council do feel
that it's an over development that was
one of the key elements and the other
key element that they mentioned was the
access
um in terms of the the development I I
will depart slightly from Bishop Stanton
Parish council's View
um I've used the ringmore road to come
into tinmouth a few times because of
traffic on the a381 has been substantial
or blocked because of Road works or
accidents
and when you come down that road and you
look across the river at the the bit
that's open to the to the left as you're
heading towards Sheldon
you see an eyesore that's effectively
what that that boat yard is currently
it's an eyesore it's a Brownfield site
it needs Redevelopment of some kind
the main issue is of course that we're
talking about how that development looks
and what it actually represents but I
want to take a few inconsistencies in
the way that the council approaches
certain aspects in relation to this
development
it is outside the settlement limit but
that hasn't presented prevented this
Council from looking at other sites for
accommodation and employment that are
outside the settlement limit
that are also within the undeveloped
Coast so we're not taking a we're not
taking a consistent view here
we're not taking a consistent view of
harm to class grade two listed buildings
or structures or Heritage assets we
don't take a consistent approach there
now actual fact I'm thinking one in
Newton Abbott is due to come up that
will not affect just one directly but
will affect another very very close by
so from my perspective I I'm not
entirely sure we can justify with the
distance from that Heritage asset
anything more than the fact that there's
a view impact and as we all know from
repeated discussions nobody's entitled
to review
and that is quite an important aspect to
to remember and particularly it's not a
residential view it's a people should be
focusing on the road ahead not
necessarily looking to left and right
in terms of impacts on the bridge itself
we passed some time ago a building
construction at the very end of the
bridge at the tignmouth side which was a
complete
detraction from the buildings around
it's a modern glass fronted building
Blockhouse style as you approach the the
end of the bridge so from from that
perspective we're again looking at
design and development process which
isn't consistent if we're going to take
an approach here
the beach Huts that were mentioned
at the West End of the um the
development we talked about or the
officer detailed about the walk from the
car park to those Beach huts
but anybody who lives in dawlish will
tell you the dawlish beach Huts are not
accessible by car it's a long walk along
a sea wall
and if you want to take stuff to and
from it you're going to have to pull a
cart along that sea wall
and you're going to be pulling a car and
this potential potentially pedestrians
walking along backwards and forwards so
there are there are there are
inconsistencies in the way that we view
things and I don't think that's a
justification for a refusal on the basis
of where the beach Huts are in relation
to the car parking because we already
know that's an example in dawlish
in terms of the actual height of these
buildings
um I understand obviously from the other
side of the river they will look
imposing as a frontage on the river but
actually if you're looking at the from
the other side of the river
where those buildings will interrupt the
skyline you see Estuary Court Morrisons
and a very large ugly and brown
embankment
and that's an element of that particular
site that is is going to be addressed
you will not have a very ugly Brown
embankment and an industrial State and
an eyesore
across the river you'll have a properly
developed nicely designed
Development Across the River that will
give a better look for people coming
from Bishop Stanton into tinmouth and
coming from tinmouth towards Bishop
Stanton the only thing I can't overcome
as an objection is the access I think
the access remains a problem and that is
that is the the one area that I'd be
looking for a little bit more
information thank you very much
thank you for that
I'm going to ask obviously you made some
um big points there as it were I'm going
to ask if officers have got any
responses to any of those at that point
or if you want me to come back you yeah
please
yeah so to respond to some of the points
that were raised so um the consistency
of decision making so
um there is reference in the officer
report to an employment scheme that was
granted consent in the undeveloped case
I was the case officer for that
application and it was further up the
Estuary so it was closer to Newton Abbot
and that again like this site was a
balancing judgment you've got to
consider the local plan as a whole
You've got to the way the policies
together
um
the reason that consent I recommended
approval of that scheme is because the
scale of the building was quite small
it was immediately adjacent to existing
office development and it replicated the
appearance of that development
and the scheme was supported by a
Convent a convincing and deliverable
soft Landscaping screening scheme which
would mean that essentially there'd be
tree planting immediately in front of
the building to enhance what was kind of
some scrub vegetation there at the
moment which over time would grow and
would screen the development
there was also
um a high chance that that scheme would
be deliverable and would be likely to
come forward as it was put put forward
to us so
yeah it's it's important I think to make
that balancing Judgment of every
application
um it is possible to support development
in the undeveloped Coast if you feel
that the other policies of the local
plant you know really do require that
development to take place the reason why
I haven't reached a recommendation of
approval for this scheme is simply due
to the scale of the buildings in this in
this case the concerns around the
deliverability of the development as a
whole and the absence of screening
uh so that's the first point
um The Heritage asset I think
like every Heritage asset is different
you can't sort of say oh
um this grade two building has these
characteristics
and that's therefore applicable to all
grade two buildings that's that's just
not how it works so every every listed
building has its own special interest
and its own Heritage value
and in this case which is quite unusual
we have the applicant's own Heritage
consultant advising us that the scheme
would result in less than substantial
harm
um so we really do have to take that
quite seriously and the other the other
point that I'd like to raise about the
the landscape impact is that the
applicant's landscape Consultants
considers that the scheme will have an
adverse impact on the landscape and I
take your point about
um councilman about the um there is
other development on this edge of
timmouth which is large and Visually
obtrusive
such as the um the the flat blocks which
um you know do take away from the
landscape quality of the area but then
it's a case of do we want to add to that
harm
I I think our policy environment is
quite clear that we shouldn't
and then the other thing to bear in mind
is that
um the site will be seen both during the
day and at night
um at night the large brown expanse of
the um sort of manufacture of the
exposed Cliff behind the site will
appear in darkness but these buildings
with their large amounts of glazing will
be lit up so the impression of
development during the night will be
greatly increased during the day it will
it you know it will blend more with the
surroundings uh okay yeah
um oh do you want me to answer on the
highways as well
yeah okay okay
thank you for that
um can I open this up now for debate uh
councilor Dewhurst you've indicated
you'd like to speak please
thank you very much chair
um so
I look at this and there are
um as our officer in her very good
report
um has has mentioned
a large number of really concerning
issues the loss of of a green
infrastructure that the loss of
um
the sea uh the 800 square meters of uh
of Coastline I think is really really
concerning particularly as this Council
has declared
um a climate an environmental emergency
that concerns me greatly that the
Heritage aspects
um we talked a lot about Sheldon bridge
and its grade two status but there's as
we heard
um from the speaker in against this
application there are
um
other grade 2 properties in the Strand
in ringmore one of the gems of the South
Devon coast
and to to have
the kind of
really in your face development on the
other side of the river from there I I
think is is is just hugely detrimental
um I think the lack of Landscaping on
the site
um is is is really concerning just it
just appears to be just one little tiny
sort of patch of of green there
um and and and nothing else so the
starkness of this when viewed from all
of views uh around the the the Estuary
will really sort of pull it out and I I
think be really detrimental
um I'm also concerned about the uh the
public right-of-way uh I would have
thought that that was something that uh
the applicant might wish to uh
um help the the local community we with
that
um other issues we we heard about
um
affordable
office space affordable Workshop space
but there's nothing in here that I can
see that actually says that they're
affordable and I'm not quite sure what
affordable
um industrial space actually is
um is there is there a sort of
definition
um of that
um so I I do I do commend the applicant
for bringing something forward but
personally I really think it needs lots
more work before it becomes really
something that certainly for me I could
support and therefore for that reason
I'm happy to
um propose uh chair
um that we we recommend refusal
um on the grounds are set up in the
papers thank you thank you for that
councilor um Dewhurst I didn't know if
you wanted to ask I can ask the officers
to consider your point on the affordable
industrial space and see if there's any
other response to that but I'll see if
there's anyone else who wants to come
into the debate as well I have councilor
hook
thank you very much
um yeah um well I started thinking about
this site I think in in the sense of
um
local plan policy which is where we
should start and again I I want to thank
Jennifer for her
um summing up of um the position of the
council
um
and when I balance that local plan
policy I come to the same conclusion
that really
um
going into the detail of the technical
reasons which is what I started to do
um didn't really even if um I think I
was concerned that the applicant had
submitted information that we were
unable to look at and that did concern
me in particular if there's new
viability information that particularly
concerned me and my starting point was
to be concerned about that and wanting
to have a full set of information on
which to base any decision that I made
but as I thought more about the
technical reasons
and the substantive reason I thought
well even if all those technical reasons
and that information that was provided
helped me maybe put those to one side
and dismiss possibly those technical
reasons none of those would deal with
the substantive reason
the primarily the um design and the
massing of the design
would not be dealt with by any of those
matters
um I mean it's interesting the viability
information because as I started reading
through as well I thought why are we
considering the viability of the
proposition because normally of course
you wouldn't do that it's up to the
applicant to decide whether a proposal
is economically viable it's not for us
to question that but the reason we're
doing that of course is because this
site would require us to have affordable
housing being outside the certain more
than four dwellings we have a
requirement for there to be affordable
dwellings and that's exactly what West
Timmer needs so on that basis you could
start thinking well okay we'll we'll
look at this
but then when you realize that the
affordable housing is not being proposed
that's where the viability comes in
because then you could say as as exactly
it says in the officer report if the
application as a hold could convincingly
demonstrate that the public benefits of
the scheme were sufficient to justify a
holy market-led
holy Market dwell in development then
the parliament Authority May in be in a
position to support a proposal with no
affordable housing so that is why we've
had to go away and look at viability and
that's why I was concerned that we
hadn't been able to look at the
applicant's OWN
more up-to-date viability evidence
but then even reflecting on that and
even if it was viable and even if it
could provide affordable housing units
it still doesn't deal with the
substantive issue of the design and math
in which quite frankly is huge that
office block is huge the residential
units are huge
um although the design design of the
residential units is acceptable maybe in
other locations possibly not that one so
the conclusion I've come to is that
I I cannot um see this current scheme
as satisfying that overriding
substantive objection but I can see
maybe another scheme would and and I you
know my advice would be to go away look
at it again and come back with something
else because you know obviously there's
public support for this um a degree I'm
not saying it's not the whole of
timmouth obviously there are there are
objections but there is a good deal of
support and you know it would be nice to
support a development on this site this
isn't the right one and I and you know
I'd like to see something else come
forward thank you
thank you councilor hook
um we've heard from several people who
are against the proposal and we have in
fact before us a proposal
um on the table to refuse as set out
from cancer Dewhurst so can I
thank thank you Council you're seconding
that proposal
um are there any other members who wish
to make any comments or
have any more clarity at this point
before we go to a vote Council McGregor
thank you thank you chair um I just want
to talk uh briefly about a point I
forgot earlier which about is about the
um the squaring off of the site in terms
of the uh
883 uh square meters of of uh tidal
tidal area lost
um there's a helpful illustration
provided
um on page 16 top of page 16 on the on
the report that actually shows the
intention Once Upon a Time was for
two or three football pitch sized areas
to be reclaimed from the S3 for that
site back in back in the in the 70s and
80s which which didn't come to pass
but what we're actually seeing here is
the have the footprint of the current
site
is not largely increased by the
um by the by the uh change to the sea
wall That's proposed it actually is more
of a squaring off and an infilling of
bits behind that and I don't think we
really should judge that too harshly in
terms of our environmental uh and
biodiversity
declarations because in actual fact a
lot of that title is directly impacted
already by works going on at the
Boatyard so it's Disturbed
um it's a disturbed area it's not it's
not a quiet uh piece of beach halfway
along the S3 where there's nothing
around it and the current
design of the site means that there is
potentially leaching of of uh chemicals
from the site into the the S3 around the
Boatyard anyway I'm not saying that's
that's particularly bad but if we look
at the the design of the the port
um there is there is leaching from the
port uh in terms of product that that
blows off from boats and and lorries
into the into the water by the by the
port so you know from that perspective
again I don't know if that impact is is
as great as being implied thank you
thank you for your points um I don't
know if officers were going to come back
on any of that but we do have a proposal
on table and it has been seconded so
I'll give them a moment for offices if
there's anything they want to to
reiterate on that and can you clarify
the the loss of space as I understood it
was
838 square meters is that I made a note
of that when it was said before
yes thank you chair I just wanted to to
clarify that um so we've got this area
of 838 square meters it's for the the
teen history is the entirety of the Teen
Estuary is a County wildlife site so
this isn't just
um uh you know land around the port and
we do appreciate that there are
potential contamination risks at the
moment arising from the site and that
resolving those contaminated
contamination risks is a good thing but
we just don't see that that positive is
outweighed by the the Reclamation of
this large area of land it's encircling
with a a wall That's only necessary
because of the flood risk to the
Residential Properties and then the
subsequent loss of this intertidal
habitat so it is it is a designated
County wildlife site at the moment
thank you for that clarification
um so we have a proposal as set out on
the the document in front of you members
that has been proposed by cancer
Dewhurst has been seconded by councilor
hook and we're going to go to the vote
please members but it is by roll call
so I'll leave over to Chris to call out
the the names and take the details thank
you thank you chair
so we'll start with councilor Bradford
councilor kolkluff
councilor Dewhurst
councilor hook
councilor Jeffrey
councilor Kurzweil
councilor McGregor
councilor Nutley
councilor Ross councilor councilor
Goodman Bradbury
and councilor John Patrick
sorry yeah that's
um eight four two again so it's been
carried so the proposal has been carried
so
um that item has been refused as set out
um we will now move on to the next item
on the agenda thank you
foreign
major decisions summary to to concern
ourselves with
but we do have appeal decisions to note
I understand what people are going to be
leaving us but I will just take us
through that
um
are any questions or any comments to
make on the appeal decisions that we
have on the agenda
hope our members happy to note that can
I see a show of hands from that point of
view
thank you
so everyone voted in favor to to note
that so that is the conclusion of the
the planning meeting today thank you
very much for your time today
um and for all of the the speakers and
people who came along today
if I can ask you to stay in your seats
until we confirm the filming is off
thank you